ça fait 15 ans que je suis sur la route
16 ans maintenant à tu je suis en
itinérance donc je suis parti pour un
temps totalement indéterminer je sais
pas du tout ce que je vais croiser les
gens que jeis rencontrer les endroits où
je vais me poser donc j'essaie de Pier
un maximum de
d'éventualité est-ce que il y a quelque
chose que tu recherches à la fin de ce
ce Tour de France le but il est dans le
voyage en soi c'est pas l'arrivée que je
vise c'est vraiment le voyage en
lui-même j'ai l'impression d'être un peu
en mar de la société toi en marche de la
société non je suis en plein dedans
parce que chaque jour je rencontre des
nouveaux gens je suis sur des lieux
publics je j'échange je partage il y a
besoin de partager salut c'est leilla de
brut et aujourd'hui je me trouve à une
30entaine de kilomètres de Brest alors
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de Greg
ça fait 16 ans qu'il est sur les routes
de France à enchaîner les petits boulots
à gauche à droite mais ça fait depuis 15
mois qu'il a entamé un tour de France à
pied il a une jument tu viens ma belle
un chien attention mon ganche une
poule et un bou ferme ta gueule tu l'as
appelé ferme ta gueule voilà un petit
clin d'il Camelot il m'a envoyé un point
de localisation pour pour le retrouver
donc je sais pas exactement où je suis
j'ai juste
entré de point de localisation dans mon
GPS et j'ai atterri ici et je crois que
je suis au bon endroit coucou toi salut
à vous comment ça va bienvenue ben ça va
eh tu es sérieuse quand c'est pas lui
qui vient c'est toi qui va l'embarder
chaque jour c'est on rerange tout on
repactage tout pour pas que ça bouge sur
la route c'est un perpétuel
recommencement j'ai l'avantage d'avoir
la jument qui me porte qui est capable
de porter pas mal de de matos de par son
poids elle fait près d'une tonne donc du
coup elle porte à peu près 100 kg qui
équivaut à moins de 10 % de son son
poids pour elle c'est pas pire que
n'importe quel cheval qui a une selle et
un cavalier qui vient lu lu grimper sur
les reins donc il faut vraiment que soit
ce soit carré c'est ta brouette de
voyage voilà c'est ça c'est le petit
charieot qui me permet d'avoir toute une
logistique àortter de main une partie de
mes provisions avec ma gamellerie pour
le café et tout et puis le panneau
solaire qui vient pardessus histoire
d'être autonome le plus autonome
possible donc là on va pouvoir aller
chercher les loulous non pas bon pour
toi pas bon pour toi ferme ta gueule tu
bienens allez allez ouais super
c'est très bien tu sais tout faire en
fait mais si je fais pas il faut que
j'appelle du monde pour le faire et donc
du coup que je
paye comme je disais moi j'ai aucun
revenu fixe pas de Ra pas de
chômage par contre j'ai du temps du
temps pour apprendre du temps pour faire
c'est là qui est ma
richesse un cheval qui a plus de pied
c'est un cheval mort donc tous les jours
c'est vraiment une grande attention à à
avir j'ai pris un cheval parce que
lorsque je voulais me poser dans le
verrecor j'avais projet donc de
m'installer là-bas d'avoir du terrain et
avec des amis on avait cette idée de de
résilience de monter des projets de
d'autonomie et puis d'essayer de
d'améliorer un petit peu les choses
autour de nous je me suis dit ben je
vais arrêter la motorisation et je vais
passer à l'attelage j'avais monté un
petit F truck des pizzeria mobile un
plancher des arceaux une grosse bâche
j'ai mis mon four à peint dedans et puis
on tracit comme ça à travers le le
plateau et les les vallées
avoisinantes jusqu'au jour où
malheureusement ben on a pris un gros
carton un vieux qui nous a rentré dedans
à 70 km/h sur la route par derrière il
nous avait pas vu et donc ben fin du
rêve ça a détruit tout le matos moi j'ai
eu multiples fractures elle par miracle
elle a rien eu la peur de sa vie du coup
depuis tout ce qui est exercice de trait
c'est très difficile c'est un peu con
pour une jument de trait qui veut plus
tirer me disait de m'en débarrasser
parce qu'elle servait plus à rien je me
débarrasse pas des membres de mon clan
juste parce qu'ils ont pas l'utilité
première auquelle on s'attendrait toi et
ces animaux vous formez un clan c'est ça
c'est ma famille c'est mes enfants elle
c'est la mieux LTI une petite poule de
luxe les poules c'est très sociable
c'est plutôt câlin allez ganèche tuip
ferme ta gueule en
avant voilà après j'essayie de respecter
le code de la
route je suis considéré comme un
véhicule avec les animpp Tup tu vas
trottoir attention en voiture tout le
monde à droite tu lip droite trottoir
super à 19 ans j'ai fait mon sac j'ai au
revoir à ma mère puis je suis parti à
l'autre bout du pays donc je suis parti
à Rennes j'avais juste mon sac pas sous
en poche juste des rêves plein la tête
puis j'ai continué à bouger un peu après
j'ai trouvé du boulot à doirnunet j'ai
eu mon premier appart donc j'ai goûté un
petit peu au début de la
vie standard avoir un boulot des charges
des loyers hpra cher fin du contrat j'ai
continuer à bouger puis j'ai eu une vie
un peu rout comme ça en sac à dos les
moyens de revenu à cette époque en sac
c'était un petit peu
d'intérim un peu la manche j'ai essayé
la Manche quelqu temps je me suis mis à
faire du spectacle de rue un peu de
musique j'ai craché le feu pendant
quelques
années
merci donc voilà les gens quand ils
passent à côté de toi ils te disent
quelque chose tu as déjà eu des gens qui
ont été hosti c'est arrivé j'ai eu de
tout je suis confronté à tout style de
population du coup parce que je suis sur
un lieu de passage
beaucoup sourit beaucoup s'interrogent
certains s'arrêtent m'encouragent
d'autres s'arrêtent m'insultent que j'ai
rien à faire
là tu es bien B allez courage pe pipi en
ce moment on est plutôt à 3 He de marche
par jour l'avantage un petit peu de de
la
technologie ça me permet d'avoir les
cartes de pas multiplier les
cartes routière et puis du P parce que
tu savis quel parcours tu allais faire
quand tu es parti sur absolument pas
c'est au jour le jour j'ai dit Tour de
France le maximum par l'extérieur
possible après aucune étape est prévue à
l'avance c'est ce qui met un peu le
piment et la magie dans dans le
voyage merci vous partez là alors nous
on est en itinérance sur le Tour de
France donc àierance carrément
c'est4 non non non je peux vous mettre
sur Facebook il y a pas de souci j'y
suis déjà on va rester une petite heure
al on est bien en niveau temps il est
midi
elle aussi tu l'as sors ah ouais
ouais quand
même petit bout de pain
tiens ferme ta
gueule
non qui décli vraiment là tu t'es dit je
pars le
déclic c'était un nouveau ralb et une
grosse déception j'ai fait une sorte de
gros burnout là de de la ville la ville
Paname quoi ça fait des années que je
bosse dans le bâtiment dans toutes
sortes de métiers différents j'ai failli
trouver un terrain 8 9 hectares le
vendeur était opé les copains étaient
opé on avait la tune on pouvait tout
faire sans compter voilà le monde paysan
chasseur du
coin qui sont pas pour que des bicniqu
au cheveux long viennent s'installer et
proposer quelque chose de différent qu
ça appelle des B bah des routes c'est
des mecs qui pensent différemment des
des mecs qui ont qui sont pas forcément
dans la
convention travail à part
et et on ferme notre gueule donc là j'ai
vu ce rêve s'envoler et par des Pises je
dis bon ben j'en ai marre je me casse
qui galérer autant me faire plaisir je
vais reprendre la route et puis au final
d'être sur la route ça me permet de
prendre plus soin des animaux tu veux
ça sur les quelques fois où j'ai essayé
de me sédentariser au bout de quelques
mois quelques années verc inclu en fait
je tourne vite en rond et je commence à
avoir envie de revoir de de nouveaux
paysages rester tout le temps au même
endroit en fait au bout d'un moment s'il
y a certaine lassitude qui peut
s'installer
câin tu viens câin
C
allez tous les points verts c'est des
endroits où j'ai bivoqué je suis passé à
cabreton SEOs mais voilà tout tout le
long tous les petits patelin à Cha as
trouvé des endroits sympas où tu pouvais
dormir tranquille dehors sympa plus ou
moins mais au moins herbeux parce que
c'est la bouffe des animaux c'est mon
taf c'est mon obligation chaque jour de
leur trouver de quoi de quoi les
sustenter allez les doudous on y
vaarrête pour l'eau ouais
on n' pas bu à la
pause il chif
hein droite droite droite droite droite
droite tu viens ma doudou allez viens on
débatte tulipe allez tulpe tulipe tulipe
donc là on est revenu sur là où tu étais
hier parce que ce spot il est c'est un
spot qui est bien pour dormir ouais
parce que il y a de l'espace il y a de
l'herbe il y a un point d'eau pas loin
on est sur un lieu public enfin il y a
un monsieur qui vient poser ses chèvres
et ses moutons pour faire de
l'écopaturage pour entretenir le lieu je
l'ai croisé hier et qui m'a dit que je
pouvais me poser il m'avait dit derrière
l'abaye mais il y a pas assez
d'herbes louout c'est pas un mouton on a
un joli mur avec des trous donc ben on
va essayer de composer un truc sympa
avec ça
ta FAM comment il VO un peu ce tu fa
voy ma
mère comme toutes les maman toujours
très inquiète mais avec les années elle
a pris
à prendre confiance en son Fils son et
en ses
capacités je la tiens régulièrement au
courant des bivoig des points où je
m'arrête pris un petit rituel tous les
soirs quand j'atteends un nouveau spot
je lu envoie un petit point GPS pour
pour lui dire où je suis comme ça fait
une petite croix sur son sur sa sur sa
carte de France après ma famille on a eu
pas mal de désaccord il y a pas de
ranqueur ou d'animosité mais pas
forcément de compréhension moi de leur
vie et de leur part de la
mienne alors donc voilà ça c'est mon lit
c'est ça sur le tapis du
book concrètement ça donne quoi toi tu
es allongé là c'est ça et là il y a le
book là il y a le Bou et le chien il se
met soit ici soit à côté de
moi quand tu vois ton cheztoi par que
ton cheztoi c'est ta maison ouais des
fois tu es pas en train de te dire bon
j'aimerais bien quand même avoir un
appartement une maison à moi c'est plus
difficile de voyager avec un appartement
sur le
dos bon ben du coup he je vais aller
coucher la
poulette
hop là
tac la petite est couchée je prendre mon
petit
savon ma flotte
on va laisser celle des animaux et je
vais aller prendre ma douche il fait bon
en plus il y a pas de vent ce
soir et voilà
confort c'est le petit coup de frais qui
vivifie après la
journée tuas pas mal d'aliments comment
tu fais pour pour te payer tes courses
comment tu gagnes ton argent je rends
service à des gens sur sur des petits
travaux qu'ils ont besoin à faire des
fois sur du service des fois pour des
entreprises aussi après je me refuse au
salariat parce que pour moi c'est une
forme d'esclavage avec plaisir je
travaillerai pour contribuer au
financement de notre société
malheureusement vu ce qu'on fait de
notre argent public j'ai plus envie de
leur donner donc quand je travaille je
travaille pour moi et pour les gens avec
qui je travaille je fait un petite
salade style
landaise donc salade sucrée on a eu la
chance de croiser un mec qui bosse en en
restauration pas très loin de de là et
qui nous a ramené les restes de cuisine
les inv
vendu du coup qui va nous permettre de
faire une partie de notre repas ce
soir un petit peu plus vite comme ça
VO tous les soirs ça finit comme ça la
journée ben ouais écoute petit temps de
détente repos on réfléchit à la journée
qui vient de s'écouler à celle qui va
venir comment tu te considères toi un
vagabond un nomade j'ai pas de
définition à proprement dit j'essaie
d'être moi déjà d'être en accord avec
moi-même avec ce que je pense avec les
valeurs qu'on m'a inculqué depuis que je
suis
petit trouver peut-être des nouvelles
qui me correspondent mieux après ce que
je suis on peut le qualifier ouis de
vagabond de marginal de nomade
de connard pour certains de héros pour
d'autres de modèles ou de mec lambda
donc ni plus ni moins qu'un être humain
parmi tant d'autres une goutte de plus
dans cet
océan